so if there was a big bang or some
origin to our universe then it makes
perfect sense to ask you know what
happened on the Tuesday before our big
bang in our universe I personally think
the best way to think about the Big Bang
is extrapolating from the laws of
physics we know and law that understand
today when do we go in backwards fashion
going backwards in time when do we lose
connection and contact with physics that
we can make predictive statements about
and for most people I would say that
goes back from today back 13.8 billion
years up to about a mic second or maybe
a nanc and then if you try to go any
time before that nanc after whatever
either the origin of our current
Universe the origin of time we really
have no idea what there could be so all
these things are possible I would say
they have varying degrees of frul to
them